wild horses are known as a symbol of the
west and nevada has most of any state
and this evening controversy continues
as the federal government captures these
animals this is an issue our eight news
now i-team has been following for
decades the i-team's vanessa murphy is
here with the latest on the video
showing how the animals are being
treated vanessa
yeah so far five wild horses are dead
because of this operation by the federal
government the bureau of land management
claims they had pre-existing conditions
one example being blind in one eye wild
horse advocates argue these deaths don't
have to happen and many of the horses
that survive being captured are treated
inhumanely
slam the fall to the ground full gets
back up they slam it again a second time
tie it up and then tie it to the atv
slammed to the ground
a helicopter flying within feet of wild
horses the animals clearly in distress
this is the buffalo hills complex wild
horse gather an area about 70 miles
north of reno the bureau of land
management claiming the horses need to
be removed for reasons like protecting
the land wild horse advocates say
oftentimes the blm puts ranchers
interests ahead of wild horses laura lee
heads the group wild horse education
which filmed these videos we continue
the fight against abuse continue to
expose it
congresswoman dina titus introduced the
wild horse and burro protection act of
2022 which would put an end to the use
of helicopters in the roundups lee says
she's hoping video like this helps drum
up support for the bill and stop abuse
like this a lot of what you'll see if
you did it as a horse owner you would be
under investigation but in this instance
it's happening on federal land where the
people perpetrating the conduct are also
the people policing that conduct
and it's a little insane
this current round-up began on july 1st
the blm reports capturing nearly 200
horses so far the goal is to capture
close to double that this is an issue
that's complex again the i-team has
covered it for decades you can watch
previous stories at 8newsnow.com